la mode parlons chiffres on parle on
était voici la collection printemps
étaient 87 présenté lors de la semaine
de la haute couture il ya des choses
faciles à porter et puis d'autres
agréables seulement à regarder
nicole cornu langlois jean marie
lequertier en ont fait une sélection à
voici pile ou face les couturiers joue
le bicolore et longue aux rôles
aficionados et d'un trio de carmen
prémices pour lanvin homme femme de soi
lascive insolente et burity et du noir
et blanc
pour philippe venet bon chic bon genre
crois qu'il a
percutant pierre cardin aux le cosmic
clic tôt le jour délirant le soir
guy laroche jeu gagnant rigueur
perfectionnisme
eric mortensen pour balmain créé le soir
hypocrite grandiose d'un copé impudique
de l'autre
collégienne les femmes de ted lapidus en
robe de soie prince de gamme
apparemment sage la femme en pied de
poule bleu et blanc de givenchy je peux
enlever sa veste
bridor et patinoire ou pastilles blanche
les robes de gérard qui part pour nina
ricci une sautière les robes de rayures
de thau rente est carrément impertinent
le pouf de christian lacroix pour pas
tout une mode clin d'oeil tel qu'on aime